auf und davon mit immobilien
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein workshop in florida der
amerikanische traum von marina maria und
micro stettler vor der eröffnung geht
einiges drunter und drüber zum glück
sind helfer aus houston angereist
bella italia
ein agriturismo mit ackerland und
gästewohnungen
eva und philipp skater matti sind als
liebespaar gestartet dann kam die
trennung nun soll aus liebe freundschaft
werden
an einer stelle ihres olivenhaine
scheint der boden unfruchtbar sie
entnehmen eine probe
[Musik]
zahltag in frankreich der hof lesung
samt ihren gebäuden und
landwirtschaftlichen maschinen geht in
den besitz der familie visa über
neuanfang auch personell
zum glück sind zahlen nicht halten
[Musik]
ein frühling wie kein anderer ist man
gebrochen corona hat den bewegungsradius
sind der grand nation stark
eingeschränkt man darf sich nur zehn
kilometer vom wohnort entfernen für die
bauernfamilie visa kein problem er hof
und die tiere halten sie genug auf trab
[Musik]
auch die schulen sind geschlossen
dann hat vorgezogene ferien statt schule
mit landmaschinen rumfahren für die
familie stets
schon weiß was dürfen muss elektra
vertrauen muss man vor allem hauen kind
und es steht aber immer öfter bereit
also spurlose milchzähne unerhörtes
teleskop schalte wird steiniger als
andere firmen auch immer so ganz frei
leidet er vermisse
der automatische misst schieber ist
hängen geblieben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der 8 jährige chen ist stolz mit seinen
fahrkünsten kann er dem vater helfen den
schieber aus dem dreck zu ziehen
[Musik]
dann ist gestiegen
suppe
auch das gut
so
einen tonnenschweren misst schieber
wegzug ist nur eines von johns
abenteuern im neuen leben in frankreich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der start zur offiziellen eröffnung ist
noch verhalten
doch der erste ist schon
arbeitsreiche wochen und nächte mit
wenig schlaf liegen hinter den beiden
jungunternehmern
und 4
laut schon brummt der laden und die
mühen sind vergessen
[Musik]
ein lachen
[Gelächter]
zum eröffnungs team gehören auch vier
studentinnen
geplant ist
dass laut puls
[Musik]
gegen abend nehmen die helfer abschied
sie gehen zurück nach houston dort haben
sie ihr eigenes waffengeschäft
[Musik]
nun liegt alles in marina und mikes
händen
[Musik]
so macht wenn man einsehen denkt über
ein
[Musik]
es ist fast 11 uhr als sich die letzten
gäste auf den heimweg machen
ich
glaube
das wird gesetzes oder zucker eiweiß das
empfehlen kritik an der schweiz die
machen das sowieso nie aber ich habe mir
wieder zurückkommt bla bla bla und
und mit dem sparen
und
kürzen
und kassensturz fragt sich wie viel die
beiden eingenommen haben
[Musik]
es ist trocken und heiß in der
toskanischen mama hier regnet es diesen
sommer kaum wie in ganz südeuropa
die wäsche ist im nu trocken
für die olivenbäumchen von jungbauer
philipp jedoch könnte die trockenheit
zum verhängnis werden
als ich es bis ganz neues und da ich
auch richtig verstanden
einziges problem ist das wasser das
ist ziemlich großes problem das ich
grundstock für eine bekommen ross brawn
zu sehen
es kommt vor dass der vergangenen zeit
wann wir mit der focus bauen das mit
zwei quartale handlung
und die
qualität vorhanden und die andere ist
praktisch physik
[Gelächter]
phillips weiter matti hat schnell mit
den nachbarn freundschaft geschlossen
jetzt in der not helfen sie ihm
betriebenen sehe und das wird dass ich
auch ohne bio menü hat sollte druck wo
du die röhre durch und darf man sich
nichts
und er ist glücklich denn auch die
bodenprobe zeigte die erde des oliven
heims ist unbelastet
auch der helfer ist ein nachbar
das ganze leider nicht
mehr genutzte darstellen und ich weiß
nicht was noch mitteilt will das ist
also ein achter rang
viele sind es sind im ganzen sind acht
unter bäumen also es ist nett das ist
nötig linie große montage sondern sich
wirkliche bis 3
philipp hofft dass er die pflanzen nur
dieses jahr gießen muss hätte mehr
bestand von ganze ding hätte ich sofort
und sollte oder und dann tun im
oktober fange ich damit den oliven mit
den fahrzeugen ereignet und dann muss
das ganze theater mit dem mit der küste
erinnert machen
[Musik]
der einmalige eröffnungstag endet
trivial am schluss geht es ans aufräumen
und putzen
[Musik]
noch nie ganz aus logisch aber
ein höhepunkt steht noch an der
kassensturz
wie viel haben sie eingenommen
ein schwieriges irgendwie musik
methoden
wo mehrfachstecker es gibt so verschicke
und hätten wir ja
ja ja mal so schön war wenn man es auf
jetzt grunde hat
darüber ist betroffen vor der
marina ist die finanzchefin
jetzt muss auch noch immer sprachen und
[Musik]
eigentlich
700 dollar ein stolzer betrag für den
anfang
was genau doppelt dass viele
verschiedene stellen sich waschmaschine
nehmen
gegen mitternacht erst geht's nach hause
[Musik]
in meter spannweite hat das mähwerk
zur mehr saison hat sich bauer wiese
einen neuen traktor geleistet
das klinge kontrollieren wie viel hektar
gemacht hat
lasten oder
geht es um maschinen ist schon dabei
[Musik]
maschinen von denen noch nicht
vordergrund rücken wie sich die
schwerter vorne
[Musik]
wir sind das dream team
einmal eine halbzeit
also schönen ich sehe
dann hätte ich sie jetzt auch die radial
sachen
schon als sandro in johns alter war
wollte er landwirt werden sein großvater
hatte einen hof im appenzellerland wegen
einer allergie aber wurde sandro becker
mit der zeit bildete sich die allergie
zurück und sandro konnte doch noch
seinen traumberuf erlernen
mit 45 jahren ist er nun großbauer in
frankreich
[Musik]
macht einmal 76 tage
doctors ins hotel of the hundreds
die vsc insgesamt jetzt und der
schweizer hat bereits
expansionspläne
der wert bei saniert
nachdem er sein vorhaben wenn wir sind
jetzt mit der fläche gegenüber den peers
immer so komisch ist drin aber
nun vielleicht kennen
lorenz nicht dass der andere sich vor
der eigentlichen falter ist der muss es
nicht lange über nichts
[Musik]
einmal mehr wird es ein langer tag
und morgen in aller früh geht es schon
wieder weiter
[Musik]
derlei thalia sonne strand und meer
eine viertelstunde von der küste
entfernt im ruhigen hinterland wollen
zwei zürcher ferien auf dem bauernhof
anbieten
ein agriturismo mit sechs
ferienwohnungen und swimmingpool
[Musik]
eva hat ferien die kindergarten lehrerin
ist ein wenig überrumpelt morgen kommen
zwei töchter samt familien zu besuch und
dann haben sich unerwartet vier weitere
gäste angemeldet der nachbar hat die
tourismus empfohlen
noch aber fehlen töpfe und möbel
es hat man doch lieben unrealistische
es gibt noch so viel zu machen bis die
räume die chronik gewicht das schaffe
ich
werfe mir das auch wissen dass ich das
mit acryl mit ohne klima bietet
einfach so wie sagt man ich glaube
kraft und gestoppt
und ich bin eben ich bin ein absolutes
weg ich mir jetzt ein hotel und ich mal
eingesprungen und habe die oper
gruselige
personen boote hand und trotz sind ihnen
die bisher
getrennt die beiden haben sich
zusammengerauft
und es funktioniert philipp hat zeit und
ist vor ort eva brachte das kapital ein
und arbeitet während der ferien auf dem
hut
meine schnellste aber das durch
was hast du auch gehst
ich finde es ist finster
agrarminister ganz aufeinander hockt und
darum finde ich das auch noch gut die
lösung dass ihr etat noch nie ihre
schweiz bin und
ich weiß auch nicht wie beides und für
die philips kartenleger stimmige ohne
zum deppen und ohne sie
also ich denke sich viele gesamt schluss
antifa beide win win situation
tatsächlich für philipp stimmt's in
italien ist er nicht nur bauer sondern
auch noch gastgeber
reguläre gäste oder die eigenen kinder
ev hat hohe ansprüche an ihre
gastfreundschaft
ziel muss auch ohne sich drei
und für mich geht das dass ich für mich
ganz wichtig das brot der kreis kunst
kommerz unternehmers und ich werde
wirklich
ich mache wohl trend zur ruhe ich finde
wir können hier seine frau und kinder
brauchen da bin ich wohl
für 123 wie viele wochen haben kann ich
mich noch nie dass ich mich einfach wohl
diese momente parlament ihn prima
[Musik]
zur disposition
die hand möglich raus für da sollte und
dadurch tv genau gleich wie nicht
wirklich und ich denke dass man das
jetzt dass man jetzt vier die hand woche
mit und glück sind das finde ich genial
[Musik]
zehn wochen sind seit der gelungenen
eröffnung vergangen
mit jedem tag sind marina und mike
routinierter geworden und sind im
amerikanischen alltag angekommen
marina macht eine kleine morgenrunde mit
hündin gina
pflegt den vorgarten ein muss
denn auch das land der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten kennt überraschende
grenzen
muss gar zum ziel jorge das gehege
kommt die schickt irgendwie gar nicht
wissentlich die damit auch einer woche
und kollegen aber aus gut ist hat er
gemeint ist und wenn
der morgenspaziergang ist der einzige
moment der ruhe für marina
die beiden arbeiten unablässig
14 stunden täglich sieben tage die woche
[Musik]
ich brauche einfach immer eine
herausforderung und
ich glaube hier wird diese
ist mit fünf oder produkt hafen
zubereiten aber
aus der ist wenn man sich
auf das blicken
[Musik]
auf den herbst hat marina eine eigene
waffe kreiert die halloween waffe mit
einer soße aus äpfeln banane zimt
kondensmilch und kürbis
natürlich hat zudem mit ihm raus mit dem
franchise
gerade
[Musik]
und doch trotz begeisterung und noch
mehr herzblut
der alltag ist kräfteraubend
aber das war gegen eine chance
das größte problem ist eigentlich
mitarbeiter zwingen zuverlässig sind und
die sind zu verlassen und
ich bin dir spiels war
drin ist stress dass man auch keine
gekracht
[Musik]
viel arbeit auch in frankreich es
herrscht hochbetrieb ist das gras gemäht
wird es unverzüglich gehäckselt und in
silos eingelagert
mitarbeiter und bauern aus der gegend
unterstützen sandro
hektar oder grausam worte nur so
ja
diese sei dann auch gestern drei
in der schweiz hatte sandro rundballen
silos hier konserviert er das tierfutter
in einem flachen phase
sehr schmaler so spannend wie das
funktioniert also wie scott weiss
workflow ist
kommt tut ist am kiosk kaufen
[Musik]
sandro gönnt sich keine pause
die anhänger und der häcksler gehören
einer kooperative eine gemeinschaft aus
bauern die sich maschinen und
arbeitskraft teilen später wird auch
sandro den anderen bauern helfen
trotz der vielen arbeit sandro passt
david
träumen darf man ja für die realität ist
man sagen verantworten
[Musik]
in der schweiz servierte sandro 300
tonnen gras im jahr hier sind es fünfmal
so viel nebst 4000 tonnen mais
[Musik]
in der toskana herrscht fast schon
hochstimmung die ersten gäste sind da
und morgen schon kommen evas töchter und
enkelkinder an
der völligen chor begriff weshalb nehmen
heute haben die zürcher ihre
italienischen freunde zu einem
grillabend eingeladen
[Musik]
doch dann lief us tochter an
was ich
[Musik]
positiv
freut dass ihr drückt aber ich fühle
mich einfach super
[Musik]
sie sind losgefahren und dennis
positiven
alle helfen mit
[Musik]
der wegen beschäftigung
dabei konnten wir das nicht ich mache
dort mit dem
victory salz und rosmarin mit dabei
erklärte alltag finden das ist
unglaublich und ich freue mich so dass
ich zu viele sachen
womit man sind da der trick an
wahnsinnige motivieren
[Musik]
geliebte italy anita so wie es sich die
zürcher vorgestellt haben und
jeder hat mich sehr berührt sie so wenig
familie gefühl wenn man so ist
eigentlich kaum unterscheiden wenn man
gegen eine bestellung in köln und
österreich aktiv geht den anderen
familie mit
[Musik]
wieder haben die jungunternehmer einen
14 stunden tag in den knochen erst gegen
23 uhr sind sie daheim
mit einem t kanal bei guter laune
gehalten ist china wenn die hunde
täterin geht lässt sie für die hündin
den tv laufen
seit bald einem jahr ist das haus am
kotten take place das daheim der florida
auswanderer
was ist gewalt ist zwischen
freund erwarte sich noch was ich den
moment
marina hat das schweizer von bereits den
amerikanischen verhältnissen angepasst
als beilage gibt es süßkartoffeln
als ich ein stück schweiz heimat
selbst wenn das komisch vor mir seit
jahren selbst wenn wir jetzt jetzt
amerika aber hallo müßiggänger schweizer
wenn sie nicht amerikaner mit lieber
schwitzen
[Musik]
sie sind 24 stunden zusammen abwechslung
haben sie kaum dazu kommt der stress im
geschäft eine stete herausforderung für
das paar
das zu glauben im labor
freundschaft beziehung
balance zwischen geschäftspartnern und
gleichzeitig sie mit
[Musik]
die saison ist auch für alexandra
strengen schon um fünf uhr stand sie im
stall und wählte jetzt kocht sie für die
männer auf dem feld
unsere pulse der macht ab mittag die
können sehr einfach schnell und
restaurants bis dann einfach schneller
gott der frau ist schlicht darum
wird es immer abgewechselt
gastgeberin alexandra hat mit der
klassischen rollenverteilung keine mühe
was du mir ärgert ist dass französisch
damit geben sich sprechen
so kam es mir bin dass ich jetzt im
moment ebenso möglich mit sprache noch
nicht so so dass diese sprache nicht
geholfen
[Musik]
zu mittag gibt es etwas typisch
schweizerisches
fleischkäse
ein gericht das den franzosen fremd ist
[Musik]
rosi
die gebrüder rondo einst hofbesitzer
sind nun visas gäste
[Musik]
beruf
er war extrem
das
[Musik]
ich sage halt vielleicht kennst
doch die begeisterung für die schweizer
küche hält sich bei den franzosen in
grenzen
vielleicht sind auch alle nur müde
zum kaffee reicht die gastgeberin selbst
gemachten kuchen
[Musik]
apa
die dürreperiode hält an seit wochen
schon kein einziger tropfen regen
würden die jungen bäumchen nicht
bewässert sie würden dem sommer kaum
überleben
die zürcher dürfen den wasserspeicher
einer nachbarin anzapfen dieser gehört
zu einem agriturismo das oliven und wein
trauben an baut
die jungbauern sind zu besuch bei der
besitzerin des guts und bedanken sich
für ihre unterstützung
trotz smarthouse großzügigkeit
den zürchern ist sehr wohl bewusst dass
sie dringend einen eigenen
grundwasserbrunnen brauchen
doch die unerwarteten ausgaben bringen
ihr budget durcheinander
um als agriturismo zu gelten müssen
arbeitsaufwand und einnahmen aus der
landwirtschaft höher sein als aus dem
gäste betrieb heißt also sie müssen noch
mehr von ihrem land beackern
[Musik]
der gästebetrieb ist angelaufen hier
lässt sich schon mal ein wenig geld
verdienen aber das reicht noch nicht
ihr steuerexperte ist zu einer beratung
gekommen
im moment
in die ferienhäuschen muss investiert
werden noch fehlen in fünf wohnungen
küchen doch auch das kostet
albertus rat ist simpel ein kredit müsse
aufgenommen werden
das liebe geld puncto geld könnten eva
und philipp kaum unterschiedlicher
ticken einen kredit aufnehmen das
entspricht in keiner weise evas
philosophie und überhaupt kümmert sie
sich lieber um handfestes äußerte sich
das mir taugt auf electric von einem
anderen niveau geboten
was man halt einfach das machen wir
jetzt gerade gebaut in der kasse hat und
zerschlagt money
und bauen die zentren für den bunker
bienen vor der abhängigkeit schlechthin
ist das nämlich den alltäglichen stress
sequenzen eines oder gar tausenden ist
jetzt aber vorbei
dann habe ich als betrieb
so einfach es für alberto war philipp
von einer kreditaufnahme zu überzeugen
so schwierig ist es bei uefa.com
verstanden dass man rezepte brune muss
finanziere
aber ich hatte mich bin kreis konzept um
das merke ich das macht meine
schwierigkeiten will ich wieder netz
weiß ja was mitmachen das soll ich dir
schon lange zeit das ist dass wir so
schnell wie möglich mit einfach könne
ein konsequentes und sag mir wo cry oder
nicht für schulden machen und sowieso
menschen wie möglich zurückzahlen
sie kommen und das ico mannschaft studio
in dem du dort schließlich
ist ganz konkret müsse mit einer bank
dann
werden die beiden eine lösung finden
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
ankunft von tochter und enkelkinder
trotz freude das verhältnis zwischen eva
und philipp wird immer angespannter
auch leon gestellt
nichts geht mehr in frankreich fällt der
häcksler aus das geht ins geld dort
finden
alexandra ist stolz und
umzug in florida bei hoher
arbeitsbelastung
mike fällt wegen erschöpfung aus gar
nicht mehr vorstellen oder muss ein
bisschen bewegen - christoph matschie
marina ist nun komplett auf sich
gestellt gummi hof
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge